comme chaque semaine annabelle vient
chercher des repas à emporter
donc comme vous aviez demandé
vous avez deux carnets de végétariens
incurie de lentilles des repas
confectionnés par miguel dans son petit
laboratoire et vendus en bocaux
il ya ce contact qui pour nous est
important je sais que c'est un pro
frustrant pour beaucoup de
professionnels qui aimeraient nous
acheter nos bocco mais malheureusement
si ça marche en fait on ne va travailler
que pour que pour ce type de structure
et nous ce qui nous importe vraiment
c'est de proposer des plats des plats
équilibrés pas trop cher aux
particuliers quoi donc quelquefois
effectivement quand on n'a pas le temps
de cuisiner le week-end ou préparer la
semaine ont choisi cette option et c'est
vraiment très pratique chacun choisit
son parfum sont sa recette et sa
contente tout le monde quand ex chimiste
reconverti dans la restauration depuis
peu miguel se fournit uniquement chez
les producteurs locaux et de préférence
dans les invendus donc là en
l'occurrence dès qu'on jette qui sont
qui sont très bien mais un petit peu
abîmés
on sait que le client est un peu dit
enfin peu délicat quoi un peu difficile
et nous là en l'occurrence on va faire
du caviar de courgettes il n'y a aucun
souci quant à la fois on arrive à
valoriser le produit du du producteur
est à la fois donner satisfaction à nos
clients 200 bocaux sortent chaque
semaine du petit laboratoire de suri au
bois l'appertisation une technique de
stérilisation permet de les conserver
cinq mois au réfrigérateur et de donner
libre cours à son imagination
nous nous faisons des plats végétariens
des plats carnés des décès
des préparations apéritive comme des
pâtes et là en ce moment on a du boudin
aux épinards des pick-ups
comme je vous ai montré là il ya eu
enfin pour moi il n'y a pas spécialement
de limites en fait le récipient en verre
est consigné à hauteur d'un euro
le bocal une technique du passé remise
au goût du jour avec des qualités
gustatives et écologique qui lui
promettent un bel avenir